les berlinois ont longtemps fait l'envi
de leurs voisins européens une capitale
abordable où il est possible de se loger
sans se ruiner une réalité qui semble de
plus en plus être chose du passé
no
1 à buno
savent que marc d'alex fini depuis que
leur propriétaire a réquisitionné le
relogement bernard et sa famille tente
désespérément de trouver un appartement
ils ne sont pas seuls
[Musique]
fait tripler
fruit du hasard pendant notre entretien
une dizaine de personnes s'installent
derrière nous en attendant de visiter un
logement
c'est encore ce n'est pas si mal dit
cette jeune femme qui se souvient même
d'une autre visite libre pour laquelle
elle a dû patienter une heure
dans une ville où le taux d'inoccupation
n'était que de 1 % en 2019 la
compétition est féroce une rareté qui a
une incidence sur les prix des loyers
ont augmenté de 42 % en cinq ans
[Musique]
pour transformer ce marché des berlinois
ont proposé une solution inusité un
référendum sur la possibilité
d'exproprier les grandes compagnies qui
possède des milliers d'unités au total
la ville rachèterait donc environ 240
mille appartements pour en faire des
logements abordables
les résultats du référendum sont claires
près de 60% des électeurs berlinois ont
appuyé la proposition est-ce que ce
projet d'expropriation pourra se
concrétiser les élus doivent maintenant
se pencher sur la question
ignoré le résultat serait un scandale
croit tant le smega l'un des
instigateurs du référendum
vu la hausse des loyers il a lui même
quitté le centre de la ville pour
s'installer en périphérie
selon lui la transformation
d'appartements privés en logements
sociaux permettrait de contrôler les
prix et ainsi d'empêcher les gens de
fuir la ville en plus de s'attaquer à
l'itinérance malgré un fort appui de la
population
la proposition rencontre beaucoup
d'opposition comme celle de cet
architecte
selon lui le problème de berlin et
surtout un manque d'unité hors change et
les propriétaires d'immeubles existants
ne créera pas de nouveaux appartements
vassili d'un gros problème
expropriés ou construire pour quelle
solution opteron les autorités afin de
refroidir le marché locatif bernard est
en tout cas convaincu que les choses
doivent changer parce qu'autour de lui
de plus en plus de gens sont touchés par
cette crise du logement
[Musique]
berlinois de naissance il n'avait jamais
envisagé quitter sa ville bien malgré
lui cette idée lui traverse maintenant
l'esprit si raphaël gouvy hockey
radio-canada à berne